CBD products have skyrocketed in
popularity and seem to be for sale
everywhere from grocery stores to coffee
shops and gas stations CBD is a compound
found in marijuana but it does not get
you high advocates say it can help with
anything from muscle aches to anxiety
and it's forecast to become a twenty two
billion dollar industry by 2024
but without wide federal oversight there
is no way of really knowing what's
inside CBD so we decided to find out
Barry Peterson is here with the results
Barry you look like a traveling salesman
here yes I come with free samples so we
wanted to find out what was really
inside the bottle so we partnered with
mile high labs in Colorado to test these
nine samples of CBD that we purchased
from around the country the results
might surprise you it took two days for
senior lab assistant
Joshua kögel to test our nine samples
checking for CBD and for THC the
ingredient in marijuana that gives a
high and also for dangerous impurities
like pesticides and heavy metals so
mile-high labs we test for four
different heavy metals mercury arsenic
cadmium and lead before things you do
not want in your body the CBD craze took
off when President Trump signed the farm
bill last December the bill allows
farmers to legally grow him the source
of CBD it is a member of the marijuana
plant family but it produces only trace
amounts of THC under the bill the
government allows less than 0.3 percent
THC in CBD products here's what mile
high found in our samples none had
pesticides or heavy metals above federal
standards the THC levels were all within
federal guidelines but when it came to
dosages advertised on the label watch
out for samples were pretty much right
on two samples cheated you giving only
60 to 80 percent of the advertised
dosage then there were the over
performers a thousand milligrams supply
was really
a thousand 110% higher and one was way
over two hundred and ten percent of what
the label said this last sample claimed
five hundred milligrams in the bottle
and we measured two hundred and ten
percent so that's really concerning to
me
Steve Muller founded mile-high labs in
Loveland Colorado in the its CEO we
believe strong regulation and acting
quickly will benefit consumers and
improve the industry he testified at FDA
hearings arguing for federal regulation
to ensure accuracy in labeling right now
there's no one enforcing any of those
things it's sort of about the companies
to do it themselves somebody really is
the Wild West you just whatever you say
is what it's up on the label is what
people think they're buying yeah you can
see that from the results here that it
is the Wild West and what you get on the
Shelf is you don't really know to find
out if what we don't know can hurt us we
went to the emergency room at UC health
University of Colorado Hospital we know
that it has some medical benefits where
I met dr. Andrew Monty a toxicologist
and emergency medicine physician who has
treated people who ingested too much CBD
patients actually can become more
somnolent than would be expected right
so they come here and become very sleepy
patients can also get nausea vomiting
and diarrhea those are the most common
side effects from oral CVD and here is
another buyer beware don't turn into CBD
and turn away from medications your
doctor prescribed it seems to me that
people have no problem with paying fifty
dollars for a very small vial of
cannabidiol yet they don't want to pay
their five dollar copay for a medicine
that's actually been tested in a
randomized controlled clinical trial it
is worth mentioning dr. Monte tells CBS
News that CBD does interact with
prescription drugs but because we lack
reliable control trials and these could
be a decade away we don't know much
understanding how all of the stuff so
much we don't know including what the
dosage actually is in this no idea and
the AP did a study of some vape products
which were considered suspect like black
market and found ten of the thirty head
synthetic marijuana so really and truly
if you don't know what you're buying
don't buy it because you won't know what
its gonna do to you until it's too late
it is a buyer beware and now I wouldn't
know what to do if I was taking it but
if it was working had I been taking it I
would be reluctant to let it go it's
hard to know people Chan
people have anecdotal stories about how
well it worked yeah and as dr. Monte
says that's fine
but just don't skip the medicine that's
going through the trials and the tests
that doctor has prescribed you know and
give up and use this stuff instead
because we don't know what this stuff is
right Mary Peterson I've used CBD before
I use it sometimes to I think help me go
to sleep well I don't know does it help
you go to sleep or is it the placebo
effect yeah I think this is really going
to help me understand